[Musique]
le chef darwiné le sultan du clan des
rebelets Sadi tous issus du même village
[Musique]
sa barbe rousse est un signe de sagesse
il a été élu par les 50 000 membres de
son clan
il fait office de juge de policier et
même dans certains cas de conseiller
matrimonial
[Musique]
ça vient de Dieu
on apprend pas ça à l'école
seule une étude approfondie de la
religion peut nous apporter ce savoir
je n'ai pas suivi de formation mais si
tu connais par cœur la religion tu peux
résoudre beaucoup de problèmes mais tu
es toujours préoccupé par les soucis de
tout ton clan et je ne dors pas beaucoup
les sultans ne sont pas rémunérés pour
gagner sa vie le chèque Garou est né et
professeur dans une école coranique il
est payé 180 euros par mois
[Musique]
en Somalie les écoles sont payantes
alors pour les plus pauvres la seule
alternative pour apprendre à lire son
les écoles religieuses qui elles sont
gratuites
on y étudie exclusivement le Coran les
enfants la prennent par cœur à partir
d'extraits peints sur ses tablettes en
bois
qu'est-ce que tu apprends ici je suis
obligé d'apprendre le Coran pourquoi tu
n'as pas pu aller dans une école
générale
parce qu'on n'a pas les moyens tu y
serais allé si tu avais pu
oui j'aurais aimé
cette école religieuse accueille des
enfants
âgés de 6 à 15 ans
les filles sont séparées des garçons par
un panneau en tôle
[Applaudissements]
allez vous reposer vous savez ce que
j'attends de vous
avant tout il faut craindre le Seigneur
c'est mon conseil
notre maître vous libère que la paix
soit avec vous
pour le sultan pas de jour de repos à
peine la classe terminée il doit gérer
une affaire importante
un des membres de son clan est accusé de
meurtre
il faut régler ce problème nous allons
très vite prendre contact avec la
famille de la victime
l'accusé le voici Abderezak et policier
il a été jugé pour avoir tué ainsi
vilain checkpoint depuis peu les
autorités somaliennes sanctionnent
durement les policiers souvent accusés
d'exactions
peuvent faire appel
pour le sultan pas question de laisser
un des siens dans le couloir de la mort
une réunion s'organise dans un hôtel de
Mogadiscio
[Musique]
autour de la table des représentants du
clan venus de plusieurs régions du pays
un de nos fils qui est policier a arrêté
un chauffeur de touk touk
ils ne se sont pas bien compris
alors il a sorti son arme il l'a tué
notre religion nous offre trois options
dans ce genre de cas soit nous tuons un
des nôtres
soit les victimes nous pardonnent
ou alors nous payons une certaine somme
d'argent c'est ce que nous avons choisi
notre tradition
prévoit que nous devrons payer
l'équivalent de 100 chameaux à la
famille de la victime
cela effacera notre dette
son chameau valent environ 45000 euros
près de 500 fois le salaire mensuel
moyen
une somme qu'ils vont tenter de réunir
auprès des membres du clan chacun doit
payer selon ses moyens entre 5 et 200
dollars
bon écoutez moi tous
Abderrahmane tu vas devoir payer 20
dollars
qu'est-ce que vous faites si certains
refusent de payer
si quelqu'un refuse de payer on
l'emprisonne et on le punit c'est nous
qui donnons les ordres
si les clans s'arrangent entre eux les
autorités judiciaires n'auront plus
leurs mots à dire
les clans préfèrent s'arranger entre eux
depuis le début de la guerre civile
tant que nous n'avons pas un vrai
gouvernement national
nous ne pouvons pas compter sur la
justice de ce pays oui
le policier tueur sera relâché lorsque
la famille de la victime aura bien reçu
les 45000 euros promis
le processus peut prendre plusieurs mois
[Musique]